well back out here well back here at
home right now ccsc parents are banding
together to make sure
their kids succeed during the pandemic
they feel their voices have been ignored
and now they're calling on the district
to make changes and put their kids first
sasha loftus is live where a
demonstration is just getting underway
sasha
christian good afternoon parents are
starting to slowly trickle in here in
front of the las vegas academy of the
arts about an
hour ahead of tonight's scheduled ccsd
board meeting now they say they're all
gathering here today
to really improve our public education
system
here in las vegas and through clark
county this here is video from a
demonstration held a few months ago at
the same location
and the same groups out here today
including community schools initiative
power two-parent nevada school coalition
and break up ccsd
they claim the district has ignored
parents concerns through the pandemic
so they're standing here today to ask
ccsd leaders to put students first
focus on the kids and not the system the
event again happening here about an
hour before the ccsd regular board
meeting it starts at five
inside the theater here at las vegas
academy of the arts
no doubt many of these people here will
also sign up for the public comment
portion
to speak with trustees and
superintendent jara directly
of course stay with eight news now for
the very latest we're speaking out here
with these parents tonight
they say again this will get underway
any moment now they're just starting to
arrive
so stay with eight news now for the very
latest on air and online
at eight news now dot com reporting live
sasha loftis
8 news now